I was horrible a worst nightmare for
five years diantha Stensrud watched her
husband rod disappeared into the fog of
Alzheimer's to see him suffer this this
is just terrible old photos show
Stensrud as a UCLA football player with
a big smile but his widow says the hits
he took on the field cost him his mind
doctors diagnosed him with early onset
Alzheimer's at age 55 he talked about
those hits in 2008 just a collision like
a truck Mack truck and he told CBS
station KPIX of his fears about his
declining abilities if we get so bad I
would if I couldn't dress myself or go
to the bathroom or something like that
that's my problem he died three years
later at age 60 it was some it was just
terrible his widow is now one of
potentially thousands of people suing
the NCAA alleging the Association failed
to protect college players from head
injuries for decades the NCAA declined
an on-camera interview but said in a
statement
it works with its members to support a
healthy and safe environment for college
athletes through providing guidance and
resources endorsed by a broad coalition
of the scientific and medical
communities it calls the lawsuits
unwarranted and inappropriate yeah and
as the cases progressed you will see
that that is not true
attorney Rafi Bala Bain Ian is involved
in those lawsuits they knew very early
on the science behind this they covered
it up and ignored it year after year and
that's the truth flatout you're saying
the NCAA is guilty of a cover-up
absolutely they're guilty of both a
cover-up and willful disregard for the
health and safety of their students a
Boston University study of former
football players
reigns donated to the brain bank found
degenerative brain disease known as
chronic traumatic encephalopathy or CTE
associated with concussions another head
trauma in 91% of the former college
players brains I think we're only seeing
the beginnings of this Chris Nowinski
heads the concussion Legacy Foundation I
think it's likely that they're more
college football players suffering from
CT than there are former NFL players in
terms of gross numbers we gave up our
futures for them we gave up our brains
for them former Ohio State and
Cincinnati Bengals player ray Griffin
says the hundreds of hits he took in the
1970s left him cognitively impaired so
what did they tell you about concussions
and they told us nothing about
concussions in college
he's also suing not just for himself he
says but for thousands of other former
players it's not just my fighters their
fight as well what do you want to be
able to do for them I want to be able to
provide them the benefits that they need
to take care of themselves these people
need financial help and college players
definitely have been forgotten about
they never made a dime playing college
football though the university made
millions of dollars and billions of
dollars off of their their services but
they never made a thing and they
struggle in their life today